MANOJ SHARMA: Hello, and welcome
to the session that shows you
how to increase agility
and reduce costs
with VMware as a service,
or as I'd like to say,
what's this new hard VMware
on Google Cloud thing
that everyone's talking about?
Hi.
I'm Manoj, and I lead the Google
Cloud VMware Engine product
team.
And I'm co-presenting
with Sai, who
will join us later after my
section of the talk is over.
So we learned today how Google
Cloud VMware Engine finally
makes it super easy for you to
go from your VMware deployments
on prem to Google Cloud.
We'll also learn what the
service is all about, as well
as some key advantages
and use cases.
And then we show you
how to get started
with the service with some
cool demos along the way.
So what's the problem statement?
So let's face it, on
prem infrastructure
can be a challenge.
It can strain [INAUDIBLE]
staff because they
have to do laborious tasks
related to infrastructure
procurement, and maintenance,
and be reactive to business
needs with long lead times.
But it also means that they're
using legacy systems that
are not adding value to the
business, other than keeping
the lights on.
And therefore, they
can't scale with ease.
They're locked into what
they have on premises
and are forced to pay
for overprovisioning
and forced to provision
for peak usage.
So how do we solve this problem?
Google Cloud has created a
service called VMware Engine,
which solves the problem.
And it really gives you
a fast forward button
to your journey to the Cloud.
It's the fastest way to
migrate your apps from VMware
to the Cloud.
You get the platform
you know and love
with all the familiar interfaces
in the VMware platform,
such as vCenter.
And the service is sold on the
basis of hyper converged nodes,
which includes the service, the
software license, the storage,
compute networking,
and all infrastructure
you need to run VMware
natively on Google Cloud.
The solution is sold by Google
and is supported directly
by Google, but it has been built
with the cooperation of VMware.
And VMware fully
certifies this offering.
And you can consume
VMware basically
in a fully automated
self-service manner,
just like you consume
any other Cloud service.
And by getting all the service
needs from one company,
you simplify the way you
consume VMware in the Cloud.
I want to highlight that we
have a real strong partnership
with VMware to make Google
Cloud VMware Engine happen.
And the partnership is
not just at the technology
and engineering level.
Our collaboration
extends far beyond that
to ensure that our customers
have a smooth experience
with the service.
To find out more, I
encourage you to check out
the sessions and the
customer conversations
at VMware's marquee event that
just happened, VMworld 2021.
You can also check
out the blog post.
The link is indicated
on the slide.
And a lot of the VMworld
infrastructure, I want to note,
is actually the user labs.
And a lot of the
hands-on experience
for customers at
VMworld 2021, in fact,
was hosted on Google
Cloud VMware Engine.
So we are very happy
and proud about that.
So what we did to find out
whether the service adds value,
we surveyed a lot of IT and
application leader owners.
And we found that
the service delivers.
We found that the
service is really able
to meet the goals of the
Cloud transformation journey
that we talked about.
First, we find
that the customers
are able to provision very
quickly and in minutes
in Google Cloud and get to the
time to value to be really low.
You can run next to a
wide variety of data, AI,
and infrastructure services that
Google Cloud is known and loved
for.
You get extremely reliable, high
performance, highly redundant
infrastructure to
ensure that you
have a no-compromises
enterprise experience.
It's super important.
And the best part
is that you'll be
able to save money while
you're doing all of this
by leveraging the Cloud
economies of scale and the pay
as you go flexibility that
you get in Google Cloud.
So when we were
designing the service
we had a certain mission
and a vision in mind.
And that was really what we
call cloud-native VMware.
And cloud-native VMware means
three very specific things.
First, it means that it's a
cloud-optimized experience,
meaning that customers can
consume VMware as simply
as any other cloud
service, and take advantage
of the elasticity of
scale that I talked about
and the scale on demand model.
And you can do so much
faster than any other way
in getting your VMware
infrastructure to the Cloud.
We simplify the use
of VMware services
through unified identities,
access control, and support.
And a customer [INAUDIBLE]
has moved to a self-service
and scale on demand model
on their VMware consumption
with the service, and
have done so much faster
than was ever possible
before for them in the Cloud.
The second part of what
cloud-native VMware means
is a cloud-integrated
VMware experience.
And what this means is you can
transform business applications
with simplified integrations
of Google Cloud Services,
like Cloud Operations,
BigQuery, and Anthos.
And so you can respond
to business needs
more quickly in a more agile
fashion with these services.
A large telco provider has
streamlined their operations
management, monitoring
and logging,
coming from both
VMware, as well as
the rest of cloud conversion
into a single pane of glass
with the Cloud
Operations integrations
you have with VMware.
And the third part of
the cloud-native VMware
is the familiar
third-party applications
that you consume on prem,
as well as in the Cloud.
What that means
is you can extend
your ecosystem of
third-party apps and services
that are critical
to your business
for your various needs, such
as desktop and backup and DR.
And we've partnered
with solution providers
and third-party application
developers, such as Veeam,
Rubrik, and [INAUDIBLE].
And we've also partnered
to solve the storage
infrastructure
problem with NetApp
to provide storage
solutions for VMware.
So that's how we
bring this mission
to life with these
three elements
of cloud-optimized,
cloud-integrated, and ecosystem
enabled.
So one of the surprising aspects
of adopting VMware Engine
is that customers, in
fact, save quite a bit
compared to both
running on premises
and choosing other
options in the Cloud.
And you must have seen
these kinds of studies
many times that they
show that they save over
a three-year window.
But then you find that the cost
of initial adoption is high.
And that's not the
case with our service.
Let me level with you.
If you're going to
the Cloud anyway,
and you're coming
from VMware, there's
no better place than
Google Cloud VMware Engine,
because the platform is the
same as what you can do on prem.
And with the
oversubscription capabilities
of the VMware platform,
you get very high density
and lower cost per VM.
And what better way to
understand this value
than to hear a testimonial
directly from the customer?
So let's take a look at
a video that gives you
a good idea of how
Mitel is getting
the best of both worlds, running
the platform they know and love
on Google Cloud.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: Mitel is a modern
communications company,
leveraging state of
the art technology
with offices
throughout the world.
Our challenge is really
netted out to the four
S's-- stability, SLA,
security, and scale.
Google Cloud VMware
Engine is really
solving the stability and the
reliability platform issue.
With that, we're
able to move out
of about 15 data centers, which
gets us closer to our data
center decommission objective.
The benefit going forward
in the Google Cloud
is now we can look at different
deployment options as we grow.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
[END PLAYBACK]
MANOJ SHARMA: What
a great video.
And let me give you just
a little more perspective.
I was, in fact, involved
in the Mitel experience.
And there moved thousands
of VMs, most of which
happened on just a
couple of weekends.
And they were running
a telephony application
with voice and video needs.
And they needed low latency
and really high throughput.
And with the VMware Engine's
fully allocated networking,
fully dedicated
networking, they were
able to get
sustained performance
and not have to worry
about multitenancy
or any other customer
stepping on their toes.
And so that's how they truly
got to this best of both worlds
experience, and got from
the VMware environment
that they truly
love to Google Cloud
that they have come to
now know and love as well.
And with that, I'll hand
the baton to my colleague,
Sai, who will walk us through
the differentiation and the use
cases and give you more
examples of the goodness coming
from the service and how
you can truly supercharge
your journey to the Cloud.
So over to you, Sai.
SAI GOPALAN: Thank you, Manoj.
I'm Sai, and I'm a product
manager with Google Cloud.
Let's get right into it.
With Google Cloud
VMware Engine, you're
able to migrate to Google
Cloud without changes
to your applications.
You use the same
tools and processes,
and your staff can hit
the ground running.
From an experience
standpoint, there
is a single vendor,
Google, which
means that for your purchasing
support and service needs,
Google is there for you.
For the given that this is
a Google managed service,
you do not have to manage
the lifecycle of your VMware
infrastructure.
Google does that for you so
you can focus on your apps.
With our differentiated
networking,
you can truly leverage some of
the native capabilities that
allow your apps and
environments to be global.
But unified management,
unified access control,
and access to the same
third-party pooling
that you have built and invested
in, [INAUDIBLE] becomes simple.
You can run both
VMs and containers
in Google Cloud VMware Engine.
And this is extremely useful for
high performance applications
where locality and running
on dedicated infrastructure
is important.
Further, high bandwidth,
low latency, private access
to co-located Google
services reduces
the amount of work required
to modernize applications.
Let us look at some of the
key use cases of Google Cloud
VMware.
Customers that want to
migrate their entire data
centers to the Cloud due to
events such as data center
exits, mergers,
acquisitions, or those
that just want to extend their
data center to add capacity
in the Cloud can invest in
Google Cloud VMware Engine.
It is completely consistent with
the on premises environment.
We simplify the networking and
provide the service globally.
This also applies
to customers who
are looking to support
high performance
applications in isolated
compute environments,
and also apps and [INAUDIBLE]
that are incompatible
with other
infrastructure platforms.
For those that are looking
to develop a cloud-based DS
strategy due to events, such
as upcoming audits, protecting
against ransomware,
protecting tier two,
tier three apps,
or geographic risk
diversification can also look
towards Google Cloud VMware
Engine, given our
low cost DR solutions
and support for a wide
ecosystem of goods.
For customers looking to
support distributed desktop
infrastructures in
multiple geographies,
or those that have upcoming
software licensing renewals,
or that are looking to
address seasonality or support
with more end users
at scale, save
for their work-from-anywhere
initiatives,
our service offers support
for both industry-leading VDI
solutions with VMware
Horizon, as well as Citrix.
Finally, for those
customers who are looking
to unlock the value
of Google services
for their applications
and infrastructure,
Google Cloud VMware
Engine offers a path
towards where you can move
your applications rapidly
to the Cloud, and then
modernize over time.
We are now available
in 12 regions
worldwide with the latest
addition of Mumbai.
Then we have four [INAUDIBLE]
of SLA in a single zone in each
of these locations.
In other Cloud context,
this might not be possible.
There are customers who
want even more availability.
And for them, we have
additional zones coming up.
Please speak to your Google
Cloud sales representative
or your customer
engineer if you have
requirements for a
particular region that
is not shown over here.
Google Cloud VMware
Engine is HIPAA compliant,
and other key industry
certifications
are being looked upon.
These include ISO,
PCI DSS, and SOC.
Now, Google Cloud
VMware Engine truly
delivers a global
highly performant,
enterprise friendly, flexible
networking experience.
With simplified regional
and global routing modes,
you have one global
network with no necessity
to create regional network
designs and connect them.
This greatly simplifies and
reduces the cost and complexity
to have more than one point
of presence in the Cloud.
You can architect and
connect different parts
of your environment
easily across projects
and across regions
with capabilities,
such as multi-VPC and
multi-region networking.
With a fully redundant 100
Gbps east-west networking
with no oversubscription, as
well as a superior low latent
packet rate performance,
our architecture
really helps customers
who have applications
that are latency sensitive
or have high performance
networking requirements, such
as voice over IP applications,
and other end user workloads, as
you've heard from our customer
testimony.
Finally, with Google
Cloud VMware Engine,
your current networking
Windows solutions
can be brought to the Cloud.
We offer flexible public
ingress and egress options
with support for three
different ways for workloads
to get access to the internet.
We have the Google Cloud VMware
Engine edge, the Google Cloud
edge, or your own corporate DNS.
We also have built-in
integration with Cloud DNS,
and you can also bring
your own corporate DNS.
We are an enterprise
ready platform
that scales and supports
for your enterprise
workloads with up to
64 node private clouds
running on highly
performant and scalable
Google Cloud infrastructure,
dynamic resource management
with autoscaling enabled.
We also provide a
fully dedicated,
single-tenant high-performance
node with all NVMe storage
and with rich GCP networking,
and full functionality of NSX-T
with access to NSX-T manager.
With 99.9 SLA in a single
zone with 5 to 32 nodes
in a cluster, you have
the high availability
that is required by some of your
mission critical applications.
In addition, we also support
rich media environments
with large scale VMware Horizon
architectures supported,
as well as the ability to extend
and migrate VMware-based Citrix
media workloads.
It's fully validated by Citrix.
One of the questions
we often get
is, can I bring my VMware,
just my VMware environment,
or everything I consume on it.
How can I make my VMware
environment and consumption
better in the Cloud?
The answer is we offer a fully
compatible VMware experience
so you can bring your existing
tools and processes as is.
Whether it is your VMware Tools,
all your third party tools
that support VMware, as well as
our own marketplace services.
In addition, you can take
advantage of Google Cloud
Services, whether
it is optimizing
the embedded protection using
Cloud Storage, a zero footprint
DR solution with
[INAUDIBLE],, building
hybrid, high performance,
and availability
architectures for databases,
modernizing your applications
using containers and Kubernetes,
centralizing and modernizing
your operations management,
or enriching your app's data
analytics, and more.
In the next segment,
we will look
at a couple of these examples.
Now, as you consume
VMware in the Cloud,
you want to ensure that you
avoid switching between screens
for operations management.
For example, if you have
a performance problem,
you want to be able
to troubleshoot
all aspects of the application
dependencies in one place
rather than go to
different systems
to solve part of the problem.
While the VMware Engine
service fully supports
existing VMware monitoring and
logging codes without changes,
as you start to develop more
hybrid applications that
actually live outside of
the VMware environment,
getting all operations data in
one place will be important.
To solve this, you can use
Google Cloud's Operation
Service, formerly Stackdriver.
You collect metrics,
logs, and places
across VMware Engine and
other Google Cloud Services.
You can use built-in,
out-of-the-box dashboards
and views to monitor
your platform,
as well as the applications and
query and analyze these signals
as well.
You can see the information
from the VMware infrastructure,
as well as the in-guest
and application.
As far as the VMware
infrastructure goes,
you can see the vCenter,
the [INAUDIBLE] side
do log analysis.
This does not require
any agent installation.
Metrics such as VM CPU,
disk, and network usage
are all available.
For VM guests and
applications, you
can use open-source agents
to collect additional logs
and methods.
So if you want to troubleshoot
any application or gain
insight into the
optimization or usage,
you can do it all in one place.
As for the second
example, we will
look at a demo of how
we integrate BigQuery
with workloads running in
Google Cloud VMware Engine
to unlock the value of data
analytics for our customers.
[VIDEO PLAYBACK]
SPEAKER: The fraudulent
charges data set
is in a MySQL database
running on premises in a VM.
We have taken that data and
migrated the VM to Google Cloud
VMware Engine using HCX.
Now we can access the data
with Google Cloud Services.
To move the data
into Google Cloud,
we replicate the data
into a Cloud SQL instance
using the Google database
migration service.
We can then write
a simple SQL script
to show the zip codes with
the most amount of credit card
fraud.
As you can see, Google
BigQuery transforms that data
to appear as a visual map.
Let's take a deeper look into
the data from a global view
first.
Now we would like
to see on a zip code
basis which part of
the United States
shows the highest incident
of credit card fraud.
Here, you can see that this zip
code has an unusually higher
incident of credit card fraud.
[END PLAYBACK]
SAI GOPALAN: Now, how
do you get started?
Well, moving to the
Cloud can bring up
concerns about how to
rationalize existing license
investments that you may
have made on premises.
Now we are introducing this
program called the Catalyst
program, which provides
Google Cloud VMware Engine
users financial
flexibility to accelerate
their journey to Google Cloud.
Eligible customers can now get
one-time Google Cloud credits
that offset unused VMware
licensing investments.
You can apply these credits
against the consumption
of Google Cloud VMware Engine,
as well as any other Google
Cloud service of your
choice the following year.
This is a
consumption-based program,
and this program is available
directly through Google Cloud,
or through existing Google
Cloud channel partners
that you work with.
Terms and conditions apply.
So if you're interested, please
do contact a Google Cloud sales
representative or your
partner service manager
for more details.
In addition, with the
planned capability
of a single node
private cloud, you
can experience the
service with a single node
for non-production
quick proof of concepts.
Note that the single node
private cloud will remain live
for 30 days, after which
it will expire or reset.
During this period you could
upgrade the full production
cluster with all
your data as well.
So what are you waiting for?
As next steps, there
are a few resources
that you can take advantage of.
Google Cloud VMware Engine
comes in a hyperconverged form
factor with all compute and
storage included with the node.
However, there are cases when
you need additional storage
for capacity hungry
scenarios, such as large scale
databases, media, electronic
design automation, data
warehousing, or large
scale analytics.
You also need to lower
cost in DR scenarios
so you can protect your mission
critical data without overhead.
To solve for such
needs, we are now
announcing today
support for NetApp Cloud
Volumes in preview.
If you think that this is
going to be useful for you,
I encourage you to contact
your Google representative
to find out how you can
participate in the preview.
Contact your Google team for
a Google Search Cloud VMware
Engine demo.
We can also conduct a free
assessment with Google Cloud,
or with our partners, as well
as schedule a half day workshop
with your Google
Cloud team to go over
the results of that assessment.
This brings us to the
end of this presentation.
Thank you so much for watching.